technical question what are the major
challenges of sex in space asking for a
friend for reproduction purposes
so like uh when we're looking about
survival the human species across
generations yeah
do we need gravity essentially for sex
and space we know that gestation can
happen in space where the babies can
develop at least in mice
we know that it's possible for worms to
replicate and fly so it's possible
to for other invertebrates to show they
can make babies in space but for humans
nasa's official stance on this is that
there has never been sex in space yeah
officially
i i think
you know if we all
wonder about that
i think
humans are very predictable in that
regard again going back to the greek
tragedies i think that there's probably
someone did something close to it at
some point and so i think we we know
that sperm can be sent into space and
brought back and be used for
fertilization for uh in vitro
fertilization for humans but sex itself
in space uh you know would be i think
when we start to get bigger structures
that have a bit more privacy
i think they'll i think there'll be a
lot of it and it has to be you know this
this is a big question of who goes up
into space
it's now becoming more of
you know regular in quotes people who
have prosthetic limbs or are cancer
survivors like haley arsenau who just
went up on the inspiration for mission
so she's been a great uh researcher in
helping with a lot of the science from
that mission we have doing the same
analysis on them as we're doing for the
twin study and for other astronauts that
we're doing basically all the same
molecular profile before during an after
space flight so there we now know that
you know other people can go into space
those more and more regular joes and
janes go up
i think we'll see a lot more of it but
so far we have no data we have no video
of it either way we have no real
knowledge other than it would be it
would need a lot of velcro i think is my
only real answer there